we're gonna introduce you to quantum
computing or if you already know
something about it we hope to at least
tell you a few things you don't know
already I'll give a bit of the talk and
then hand it over to Wolff who
will give you the heart of the matter
and then he'll hand it off to me
near the end starting with the early
history what got this field started was
that certain quantum mechanical effects
are not efficiently Simula balana
classical computer and if you think
about that for a little bit you can turn
that around and wonder about well can we
use those quantum effects to speed up
other computations and at first people
didn't really know what to do there and
part of that is that we are very used to
a very abstract model of computation
that it's really easy to forget that all
computation takes place physically and
we can remind ourselves of this by
thinking about some of the ways of
grounding classical computer science in
that if you think about our models of
computation think about the Babbage
engine that some of you may have seen
over at the Computer History Museum more
than anything else these days I think it
is a triumph of classical mechanics and
on a more abstract level there are
Turing machines which are not something
you would build but are very classical
mechanical in the way you think about
them so what we're going to do today is
try to answer at least a little bit the
question what would it mean if we
instead grounded computation in the
actual physics of the universe namely
quantum mechanics
so it took a while for people to figure
out what to do there the earliest work
simply formally defined what is meant by
a quantum computation which was tricky
and then people were able to prove that
a quantum computer can do anything that
a classical computer can do in roughly
the same amount of time and can
sufficiently simulate the quantum
mechanical effects that inspired people
to look at this field in the first place
what else can they do well the earliest
quantum algorithms and I want you to
listen carefully because this is
unintuitive to most people the earliest
quantum algorithms solve certain
problems with certainty that classical
computers could only solve efficiently
with high probability and this runs sort
of counter to what most people's
intuitions are about quantum mechanics
because often for people they're the
first bit on their knowledge about
quantum mechanics is that it's
probabilistic and here we're able to do
something with certainty efficiently
that you can only do with high
probability efficiently classically ok
so I'm not going to go into this but I
just wanted to start that off by
suggesting that intuitions here only go
so far thank you
these are early quantum algorithms
spurred what what really prompted the
field to take off which was the Peter
shor figured out a polynomial time
quantum algorithm for factoring in the
discrete log problem and that really
startled people because that breaks all
standard public key encryption systems
we'll talk a little bit more about that
later
at first system worried people very much
because they looked at these quantum
computations and they said there is no
way you can make this robust quantum
systems are really really fragile and
they have bad properties some of which
we will
um I talked about later or at least
seemingly bad properties like no cloning
and so you're just not going to be able
to do error correction so what really
got the field blooming was Shor's
algorithm together with the insight as
to how to do robust quantum error
correction then round around the same
time that error correction was figured
out luck Grover figured out an
unstructured search algorithm that was
provably better than any possible
classical algorithm Shor's algorithm is
just better than anything we can
conceive of at least so far and seems
likely to be better than anything we can
do classically but Grover's algorithm
was actually provably better than
anything you could do classically but it
has a smaller speed-up we got into this
shortly after that and it was very very
exciting and then we got a little bit
discouraged because between 1996 and
about 2002 there weren't really any new
algorithms that came up there were
variants on the ones I've mentioned but
there wasn't anything really new and
part of that is because it's really hard
to figure out what's a good program here
thinking about quantum algorithms just
requires a very very different sort of
thinking but since 2002 a variety of
quantum algorithms have been discovered
and we'll briefly touch on some of those
but most of this will be an intro so
you'll need to look at references for
the variety here but will give you some
hint it might make sense in a talk on
quantum computing to start off with a
definition of quantum computer but
instead I'm going to tell you what it is
not so all of these devices that we use
all the time make use of quantum effects
so just because a computer makes use of
quantum effects does not make it a
quantum computer what a quantum computer
what quantum computing does is it
actually
changes our notions of information and
on how you process information so you go
from logic gates to quantum logic gates
from algorithms to quantum algorithms
and you have this different information
this different processing which is what
it goes on for quantum computing this is
very different from some terminology
that might sound similar like DNA
computing where DNA is really the
substrate that you're working on but it
hasn't changed the fundamental notion of
information here that's still classical
information so what are we going to do
today I'll introduce you to quantum bits
and some of their properties then we'll
take over and talk about multi qubit
systems which are really the heart of
the matter and how that leads to quantum
circuits then I'll come back and talk
about a heuristic quantum algorithm
called quantum annealing talk about some
implications for computer science and
then we'll wrap up so we're gonna go
into quantum bits now and I'm gonna
first talk about photon polarization
which might not seem very relevant but I
wanted to want you to say right at the
start that photons are one way of
realizing a quantum bit a qubit and so
the properties we talk about here for
photons is what you'll need to do to
understand quantum bits so let's start
with a simple photon polarization set up
so you have one filter and that filter
is horizontally polarized now that lets
through light that's horizontally
polarized and it completely blocks light
that is vertically polarized you can
play with your sunglasses and see this
now what if light is polarized not
horizontally or vertically but somewhere
in between then with some probability
those photons get get through but a key
property here is that if it gets through
that polarization filter
then it will be horizontally polarized
after that so what happens if we now put
a vertical Polaroid in there well now
when the photons hit the vertical
Polaroid they're all horizontally
polarized because they went through that
horizontal filter and none of them can
get through the vertical polarization
okay now I'm gonna do something really
stupid I'm gonna put another filter in
how could this possibly help because you
add a filter that can only get you less
light but we already had no light so why
would I do this well you start with
horizontally polarized photons after
going through that first filter now you
hit a filter or II ended at 45 degrees
how many of the photons get through
well those photons are about half
horizontally polarized and about half
vertically polarized sort of they're
there at 45 degrees here so half of them
are gonna get through and now what was
the key property of that Polaroid well
once a photon gets through its polarized
in the direction of the Polaroid and so
it's going to be polarized at 45 degrees
now when it hits the vertical polarizer
it now has a component in that direction
and more light gets through okay simple
experiment we almost brought
experimental equipment along but well
you can play with it so to define a
qubit in terms of photons the
polarization state of a photon can be
represented as a 2-dimensional vector of
unit length and we can take horizontal
and vertical polarizations as a basis
and an arbitrary polarization can be
expressed as a linear combination of
those as a superposition of those
and just so you know and this will
become important later you can also have
complex amplitudes so linear
combinations with complex coefficients
and that corresponds to circular
polarization for those of you who want a
physics grounding there and also I'm
using notation that is very very common
in quantum mechanics but is less common
elsewhere so I'm using Dirac's ket
notation so this bar with a bracket
afterwards just means vector it's like
drawing a arrow over it so you'll see
that throughout this throughout this
talk we went through what happens with
measurements of a photon the
polarization filters are quantum
measuring devices and quantum measuring
devices have a preferred basis they have
a preferred set of states or set of
subspaces that determine what the
measurement outcomes can be so in this
simple case when you have a horizontal
filter the basis you're thinking about
is horizontal and vertical and a photon
polarization a vertical be horizontal
will get absorbed with probability the
magnitude of a squared and will get
passed through with the probability
magnitude of B squared and any photon
that passes through the filter now has
the polarization of that filter that
those are the key properties so when you
want to we'll be talking about quantum
bits throughout the talk when you want
to when we're talking about that
just think of polarized photon okay but
any two dimensional quantum system can
be viewed as a qubit and one other thing
we'll need to do to relate it to
classical computer science and the
result
we want to get out of this is define a
computational basis I can choose any two
orthogonal States for example horizontal
and vertical to correspond to 0 and 1 in
bits but we have all these
superpositions of bits as well to play
with in quantum computation and note
that because of the complex amplitudes
we need to be a little bit careful about
how we think of these things it's it's
some tempting to say that a
superposition like I've drawn drawn
there is either and this corresponds to
a 45 degree angle photon is half
vertical and a half
sorry half vertical and half horizontal
but that's not how we would really
describe a photon right and that's also
not that great a description of what's
going on quantum mechanically it does
not mean that the particle is in the
state 0 or the state 1 we just don't
know which it means that it's actually
in this polarization state and then it
will interact with Polaroids in certain
ways and saying what a quantum
superposition means maybe
philosophically tricky but
mathematically we know what's going on
and measurements of qubits is just like
measurement of photons and the key
properties are that once you've measured
it it will be in the basis that it's
measured it's not it doesn't stay in the
superposition and that means that only
one classical bit can be extracted from
a qubit because you have to choose a
two-dimensional basis and you'll get one
of those two outcomes and you can't get
around this by making multiple copies
because of something called the
no-cloning theorem and i'm gonna hand
this over to wolfe now to talk about
even more exciting part which is when
you get multiple qubits together we have
to have two speakers is to demonstrate
superpositions
okay so you can't do very much with a
single qubit obviously so the question
is what happens if you combine multiple
of those together and create a larger
state space and the interesting thing
and counterintuitive thing is that
quantum state spaces they combine where
the tensor product as opposed to the
Cartesian product which we classically
so classically if you have a two
particles that are described by a two
dimensional vector space then the
combination of them is described by a
four dimensional space dimensions just
add up so if you have basis alpha I and
beta
I then classically in the Cartesian
product that a system consisting of two
of these spaces that are described by a
space that has the union of these basis
vectors in the quantum case that's quite
different what we have we have the
tensor product that means the basis
consists of all pairs of basis vectors
of the individual spaces and so in this
case the dimensions add up in this case
the dimensions of the tensor product is
the product of the dimensions of the
individual spaces so what that means is
that a general quantum state of n qubits
is described by a 2 to the n dimensional
vector space complex vector space so if
we take a single qubit space be with us
but the base is 0 and 1 and we construct
a 2 bit system out of two of those
spaces then it'll have the basis of 0
10200 tensor 1 and all the combinations
of these basis vectors and since these
ket's are just labels here we just write
this more simply by just having the bit
combinations as a label of the
individual basis vectors so we would
write this
the basis for the two qubit state and in
general if you have an N cubed state it
would be a 2 to the n dimensional vector
space and we label the basis vectors by
the 2 to the N possible big patterns of
the end qubits and if we know n it's
clear how long these vectors are so we
can actually write the decimal notation
or the decimal value of this bit pattern
so and just like individual qubits can
be in a superposition state so can multi
qubit systems so the general n cubed
state is a linear combination or a
superposition of some alpha I and for
all possible basis vectors and again we
normalize this to length one vector
but now the interesting thing that
happens here is that you have n qubits
each qubit is described by two
parameters so you have to end parameters
but the the state actually has two to
the N parameters so what gives here and
it turns out what that means is that
most of the n cubed States cannot be
written as the tensor product of
individual qubits yes and what and that
means most states we call those states
entangled and most states are entangled
and these are going to be very important
for our economy computation so now the
question comes what happens when we
measure states with more than one qubit
and we can do this by measuring qubits
individually and I show you with an
example what happens if you measure the
second qubit of this three qubit state
that I've written out here so and it
almost works like the single qubit
measurement we get 0 or 1 for the
measurement of the second qubit and if
we measure 0 the state will collapse in
a state that is consistent with the
second qubit being 0 if we measure one
it'll be a state that's consistent with
the second qubit being one so it's one
of the two subspaces that the whole
state gets projected into and the the
probability that we measure 0 or 1 is
just the sum of the probabilities of the
of the individual lectures that have the
1 component here sorry so that would be
a a a 3 squared plus a 7 squared in this
case and this looks more complicated
than it really is because it's just the
normalization to make this a unit length
vector so I said that entangle States
cannot be written as independent qubits
here is one particular entangled State
and it has its own name it's called an
EPR pair and the EPR stands for Einstein
Podolsky and Rosen and it's it has this
form it's a equal superposition of these
two basis vectors and I'll just show
here that this cannot be written as a
tensor product of two individual
Hewitt's and so we can assume that we
that we had so two qubits this one here
and this one here we take the tensor
product of those and that would look
like this
but we
have to have a 0 B 1 to be equal to 0
which means either a 0 or B 1 would have
to be 0 and that can't be true because
this has to be nonzero and this has to
be nonzero so it's not possible to write
the state as a tensor product of two
single qubit States so this state has an
interesting property we can go measure
one of the two qubits and we get 0 1
that's easy so far what will happen as a
result of the measurement the state will
collapse into a state that's consistent
with that measurement so it will be
either 0 0 or 1 1 now if we measure the
second qubit we're guaranteed to get the
same result as the first measurement so
these two measurements are guaranteed to
be correlated and that bothered Einstein
because in theory these qubits could be
particles photons and they could be at
the opposite end of the universe and
still be entangled and you'd get a
correlated measurement and on the face
of it that looks like you could
communicate faster than the speed of
light it turns out if you look at it
carefully there's actually no
communication going on you just get the
correlation but I'm not going to get in
the details of that so it turns out that
these states are gonna be really
important for the quantum computation so
what how do we do quantum computation
turns out there are three different or
more models of that I'm listing three
here there's the quantum circuit model
which is close to how we as computer
science people think about it and I'll
talk about that in more detail and the
way it works is we start with a known
state we apply a number of gates logic
gates to that state quantum logic gates
and then at the result we measure and
we'll get our answer there's adiabatic
quantum computation and Ellen was going
to talk a little bit about that or part
of that and the way this works is we
start with a we define the problem as a
Hamiltonian and so I'm not going to get
into deep physics but basically what
that is it's a function on States that
tells us what the energy of that state
is and so if that function has a minimum
that we call at the ground state and so
we define a function a Hamiltonian whose
ground state is the solution of the
problem that we're looking for and the
next thing is we look and we're defining
it simple Hamiltonian whose ground state
we can easily implement and then we
slowly evolve one Hamiltonian to the
other and so if one starts in the ground
state then with a high probability
depending on how fast we move the at the
end we will be in a final state in a
ground state of the final Hamiltonian
and we can read that and get the
solution to our problem and finally
there is measurement based quantum
computation which is quite
counterintuitive it starts with a very
complex highly entangled state and all
that happens is you measure individual
qubits in that state and the measurement
you perform the basis you perform it in
depends on previous measurements and so
just by measuring qubits you can create
an arbitrary quantum algorithm it turns
out that all of these three models of
computation are give or take a
polynomial factor are equivalent
so here's the circuit model of quantum
computation we start out with a n cubed
register and I call it psi and then we
perform a number of transformations and
what we do is we use one bit or two bit
quantum gates transformations on either
a single qubit or two qubits and they
collectively perform a transformation on
that state and we measure the qubits and
we need classical control to decide what
to measure and how to interpret the
results the reason we call this a
circuit model is because we graphically
represent it in some just like an
electric circuit but the way to think
about it is not as kind of qubits going
along these wires it's more like a time
axis but that's not exactly right either
but so the idea here we start with an
initial state at this point and we're
moving left to right
performing transformation u1 on the
center two qubits performing u2 and u3
and u4 and mathematically if you write
this as a transformation we have the
state we apply the u1 transformation you
to 23 and u4 so adhere a couple of
quantum gates identity that's easier
easy enough and the negation that's also
pretty straightforward we can do this on
a classical computer there gets
interesting
I wrote this T transformation it has a
parameter alpha to it and what it does
is it performs a phase shift of of the
quantum state so it changes the this is
this is a this is a unit factor and so
it just changes the the phase of the
zero and the phase of the one in a
different direction that's something
that you cannot do
on a classic computer obviously and the
other thing to note here is that this is
really a family of an infinite number of
gates because you can do this for any
alpha you can combine multiple
transformation so this would be negation
and a phase shift by 180 degrees you can
also do rotations and whereas the the
key rotates about the to face axis you
can also rotate about it's called as the
value axis so you can move from 0 to 1
and 1 to 0 and the H transformation will
do this is like for the polarization you
moved horizontal or vertical
polarization to a 45-degree polarization
that's what your H transformation would
do so you have a rotation in this axis
as well and H just does is a 45 degrees
on our polarization
you could have an arbitrary angle
transformation yeah again it's an
infinite number of possible
transformations the H has a very nice
property if you take a register that
consists of all zeros and you apply H to
each one of them you get an equal
superposition of all possible basis
vectors okay so there's one important
two qubit gate here there is more but it
turns out if you have the controlled-not
gate here together with all single qubit
gates it's a complete gate set infinite
cardinality but it's a complete set and
you can do any quantum algorithm with
that and the controlled knot is very
simple oh it looks very simple anyway it
it just flips the second bit if and only
if the first bit is one and it has a
special graphical notation that's shown
here
that we use in the in the circuit
diagrams i list this observation here
and that comes through a physics I'm not
gonna explain why this is the case it
turns out that all quantum gates are all
quantum transformations that we do are
linear in fact there are unitary just a
little bit stronger and that means that
all quantum computations are reversible
you can run them backwards and it also
means that all quantum gates do not
dissipate energy which doesn't mean that
quantum computer is free it probably
lives in a very big refrigerator that
creates micro kelvins so there's an
interesting effect now because of the
linearity if we have a superposition of
many classical inputs or base basis
vectors representing classical values
and we have this superposition state and
apply a quantum transformation to that
what will happen is we effectively
perform the computation on each basis
vector or on the classical value of
represent by each basis vector so to to
show this we can construct an equal
superposition of all possible values and
I told you earlier that the H will do
that to us and and what we can do and
there's theorems that prove that for
most functions classical functions I'm
not going to define this more precisely
here for most classical functions F what
you can do is you can define a quantum
algorithm a unitary transformation which
is composed out of many individual gates
and that this computation will perform
this quantum algorithm will compute F
with efficiency comparable to the
classical computation
and the way we typically define those is
it's the UF is the transformation that
sends this quantum state that has X in
the first part and 0 in the second part
of this register and it transforms that
into a state that has X the first part
and f of X in the second part and we
need to keep X around because it has to
be reversible so now what happens is if
you take the superposition state here we
have all possible inputs X and the
output 0 and apply UF to it what we get
is we get a superposition of all
possible inputs and their function value
so it looks on the face of it that we've
done an exponential number of
computations here by just running that
function once that seems pretty amazing
except it's not directly very useful and
I show you why if we take the example of
the logic and there's a function quantum
transformation that computes U and so it
sends X Y and 0 into X Y and X and Y and
now if you do this to a superposition
which I've written out here of all
possible two-bit combinations followed
by 0 well what we get is all two-bit
combinations as our input part and the
conjunction now that's looks nice but
what happens if you measure we need
classical information out of it
eventually if you measure this state and
no matter and what order we measure
these qubits we get we end up getting
one row of this one basis vector here
and we don't know you know which one we
get so if you think of this as the truth
table of and by doing the measurement we
can compute it in one step but by doing
the measurement we get a random row of
that truth table which is not
particularly useful
so I'll show you a slightly more useful
example and it gets a little bit subtle
here so there is a quantum Fourier
transform which is an efficient
algorithm and let me explain how it
works because it's slightly different
from the use of F that I've shown you so
if F is a classical Fourier transform
which takes some complex vector a and
produces the Fourier transform of it
then there is a efficient quantum
algorithm I call it Q which takes any
superposition here that has the
coefficients of vector a and transforms
it in a superposition of all possible
values J basis vectors J that have the
coefficients which are the Fourier
transform of that vector so and we can
use that to make use of the quantum
parallelism that we talked about earlier
and so one way to do that is to compute
the period of a function so if you have
a period periodic function f and you
have UF that computes that function then
we know we can efficiently compute a
superposition of all I together with F
SMI which has some constant amplitude
each so we can efficiently compute this
we know from the previous slide that
state and it's off itself is not very
useful but what we can do is we can
measure the second part of this register
the F sub i part and if we do that we
get a random value we don't know what we
get anything that's in the in the range
of F but the state collapses into
something interesting the state
collapses into a superposition of all
basis vectors here where most
coefficients are 0 and only the
coefficients are nonzero if if F maps I
into X now it turns out if you take this
this vector ASA a the vector of all
coefficients here and you apply the
quantum Fourier transform to that you
get another vector of coefficients a
superposition of all vectors J where
most coefficients are 0 except for those
where J is a multiple of the frequency
of the function f that's what the
Fourier transform will do for you and it
turns out if you measure J you get some
multiple of the frequency and you can
use classical algorithms to actually
compute real frequency or the period of
that function and that's that's the
essence of Shor's algorithm and it
shorts source algorithm on one slide so
what what we know from number theory is
that we can factor the number M if we
can find the period of a function f
divided here where a is some random
value that we pick and if we can compute
the period of F we can factor M and so
the way this sure does this is well we
compute F for all 2 to the N value
simultaneously using the quantum
parallelism we apply that quantum
Fourier transform to that we make a
reading we get the period of the
function or we get a we read a multiple
of the inverse of the period we use
classical algorithms to try to compute
the period and that all will succeed and
give us a factor of M with a very high
probability sure proofs that and turns
out this might fail if it does
we'll try it again we pick another
random a and again with high probability
this will succeed like so other quantum
algorithms eleanor mentioned Shor's
algorithm sorry Grover's algorithm which
we didn't put on here so these are
should we be grover on here which is a
really important algorithm the people
who invented quantum computing are
decisive mister mister thing go on a
factor is a number and we need we need
enough bits to think cover to M or
something right so so we need register
enough large enough to cover 2m so if
you take your sent 24 bit RSA key or you
need C we repeat we have to repeat the
expected value polynomial e with the
size of them okay right so the
physicists invented this quantum
computing stuff and they as Eleanor said
they started out because they wanted to
simulate or they wanted to solve
physical problems and that's one of the
big applications we can actually
simulate various physical processes
chemistry and so on
there's a big area here there's other
cryptographic algorithms there's
Holograms other than for pal equations
that can break the book when Williams
cryptosystem
then randoms algorithm can predict some
pseudonym not pseudo-random number
generators and people try to use lattice
space to cryptography as an alternative
to public key encryption and koopa barek
has some impact on that and then there
is random walk algorithms solve some
graph theory problems matrix product
verification others yes we're being
computer scientists we need to talk
about complexity and this is there are
more complexity classes more more
quantum classes too but this is a simple
diagram here the interesting classes are
eqp that's the exact quantum polynomial
time algorithms and bqp bounded err
quantum polynomial time algorithms and
they fit in this diagram here all these
inclusions are known to be proper and we
don't know anything between NP and b QP
and the idea that that this exponential
form parallelism solves all your NP
problems is not quite true and unlikely
to be true but we don't know yet so I
mean these these are the some of the
important no 1 relations here ok to make
this all work we need to as eleanor said
that quantum state is kind of finicky
and we need to preserve it so we need to
have an implementation that tries to
prevent errors and if we can't prevent
errors we have to do error correction
and as Eleanor said was first thought to
be unlikely that this is at all possible
but now we have a really very good
theory and it works really well and
extremely surprising because essentially
what you do is you do some quantum
measurements and based on the result of
the measurements you do
a sari slightly you do another
measurement and effectively what happens
as a result of that you project a state
that has an error in it onto a state
that has no error which seems like
really magic and against Steen and shore
called about Kim came up by the first
air and now it's extremely well
understood theory okay so another thing
we need to do is worry about fault
tolerance because you can implement
error correction algorithms Forex for
example in such a way that if you have a
single bit error it propagates to other
qubits and and you suddenly create multi
bit errors and your computation will not
work
so there's Boyce you have to be careful
in the way you implement error
correction for example finally there's
some threshold theorems which are known
for the circuit model and they're really
important because essentially they say
if you if you generate errors at a lower
rate then you can correct them you can
compute forever so and and that's
important because you don't want to help
limits on how many steps you can take
any algorithm so and there's different
different theorems different for
different thresholds depending on the
kind of error models what statistics
you're assuming and what implementation
you have and so on and turns out for
adiabatic quantum computing we don't
have threshold models like that so we
don't know if that scales or under what
condition it would scale so I want to
talk a little bit about heuristic
quantum algorithms so um the research in
quantum computing because we haven't had
machines quantum hardware to run on has
focused on algorithms where we can prove
superiority
but if you look at all of the algorithms
that are run on the world's computers
many many of them we don't have a proof
that they outperform other possible
algorithms we just try them and see how
they do and if empirically they
outperform other algorithms that's what
we go with and prior to having quantum
hardware that way of evaluating quantum
algorithms has been cut off from us so
as quantum Hardware emerges and we have
some very early quantum annealing
prototypes which I'll and I'll talk
about what that is in a bit as it
emerges we will be able to experiment
with these algorithms and actually test
empirically how they do and my strong
conjecture but it is just a conjecture
is that doing so will significantly
broaden the potential applications of
quantum computing it seems unlikely to
me that the only algorithms for which
quantum computing can provide a speed-up
is ones where we've been able to prove
that it can provide a speed-up it's very
hard to prove these things now what what
those quantum heuristic algorithms are
that will be effective is a big open
question but a fascinating one and the
most well-known quantum heuristic
algorithm is quantum annealing and as I
mentioned very early quantum annealer
have been built so I'm going to tell you
a little bit about that but I just want
to make it clear that this is just one
of many possible quantum heuristic
algorithms but we happen to have special
purpose hardware that can run this one
so what is quantum annealing it's a
medic eristic for optimization so like
simulated annealing or other
optimization techniques it can be viewed
when people say quantum annealing they
can mean different things and in one
case it can mean what I just said
a quantum algorithm that's a medic
eristic for optimization and in some
other cases they mean an actual physical
prescription for how to implement such
an algorithm and part of the reason that
there's a little bit of flow between
those terms is that right now the only
quantum computational hardware we have
at the moment are quantum special
purpose quantum devices which run
quantum annealing there's a question out
there as to how well they run it but
that is what they are doing quantum
annealing like other meta huge for the
particular problem you want to solve
plus a bunch of parameters that tell you
how you want to run that particular
algorithm to try to solve it and you
have these heuristics for how these
sorts of problems might solve better
with these particular parameters okay
and the intuition here is that quantum
annealing can outperform for example
simulated annealing but making use of
quantum tunneling and also this ability
to have amplitude in multiple places for
extremely toy problems we've been able
to show that it outperforms simulated
annealing and also more sophisticated
techniques like quantum Monte Carlo
methods there is no firm evidence yet
that it outperforms any if you could
take any possible classical algorithm
there we don't know whether quantum
annealing can outperform that or not and
quantum annealing is specific is really
a family of algorithms lots of different
parameters and so there are a lot of
things to play with even if the most
basic one ends up not being able to work
there are things like I'll just throw
out some terms there are things like
adding non stochastic terms the Hamill's
that looks like it could be quite
helpful but the intuitions for exactly
what terms to add and when our subject
of great research so quantum annealing
is in its infancy but it's the first
coin amount heuristic algorithm that we
can actually locally the first
larger-scale quantum algorithm that we
can run you can run simulations on a
traditional computer of what a quantum
computer would do but those give out but
at about 40 or a little bit more qubits
so as I've mentioned for for quantum
annealing you need to specify a cost
function now that gets translated to the
Hamiltonian which which Wolff mentioned
before which it basically gives the
energies of the possible states of the
system and governs the quantum dynamics
for that system but and when we find the
Hamiltonian that corresponds to the cost
function it's going to be the ground
states the lowest energy states that
correspond to the solutions we want to
find so for example you can have a spin
glass where you have spins just a
classical spin glass where you have
spins which are up and down and the cup
and you have a coupling but other of
plus or minus one between the the spins
and if you have a 3d lattice of those
that's known to be and be complete so
they're hard problems that come up here
very very quickly so in quantum
annealing we come up with this this
final problem Hamiltonian HP where the
ground state is the state we want or a
set of states that we want to come up
with the solutions to this problem but
how do we start this algorithm and
generally we need to choose what's
called a driver Hamiltonian and that's
usually the transverse field and the way
it's probably best for you to think of
this as computer scientists is that
that's the Hamiltonian whose ground
state is an even superposition of all of
the possible states in the in the space
and so what happens is we start in this
smear of probabilities and it wouldn't
be useful at all to measure at that
point because we just get one answer at
random completely at random from that
point and though information from the
problem has been injected and you slowly
decrease that Hamiltonian while
increasing the problem Hamiltonian and
if you do this for adiabatic quantum
computation and you do that very slowly
very slowly you're guaranteed to end up
in the ground state now sometimes you
can go just fast enough that there's a
polynomial speed-up and we can prove
that and then there's the question of
maybe there are other cases where it
will work even if we haven't been able
to prove it and then what quantum
annealing in again there's differences
in how the term is used but for typical
quantum annealing that cases we don't
try to run slowly what we try to do is
run really quickly and a bunch of times
and see what happens ok and so I want to
just make clear what the connection is
and the differences are with adiabatic
quantum computing so there are a variety
of meanings for quantum annealing so for
example the final Hamiltonian in an
adiabatic quantum computation can be
quorum it doesn't have to be an analogue
of a classical cost function ok and that
allows you to do much more complicated
things ok but in quantum annealing which
generally we view as a being applied to
optimization problems though some people
use it as just a synonym for adiabatic
quantum computation but they shouldn't
in my opinion
in quantum annealing where we're going
after an optimization problem there's a
the final Hamiltonian has a specific
form which is mapped from a classical
cost function and again instead of being
in the slow regime we're doing many runs
in the fast regime and also we in the
adiabatic case you want to start in the
ground state in the quantum annealing
one generally starts in a thermal state
with a distribution over States and have
some probability of being in the ground
state and probabilities being in higher
states and and you may want to take
advantage of thermal fluctuations there
including thermal relaxation to get you
back down into the ground state in
quantum annealing ok whereas an
adiabatic quantum computing none of the
above holds it's in the slow adiabatic
regime but still in cases where you can
get a speed-up we know that for
adiabatic quantum computation we have
proofs that there are speed ups and that
it's equally powerful to the circuit
model quantum computation that Wolfe was
talking about and also it's ideally done
at zero temperature where you're
entirely in the ground state though of
course you have noisy implementations in
the implementation will be slightly
noisy so that's always a little bit of
an approximation which is why these
things a little bit merge into each
other and and also the quantum the
emerging quantum annealer z-- the
earliest quantum annealer come from D
wave and they run in the regime that
I've mentioned for quantum annealing so
they you can only specify cost final
Hamiltonian that corresponds to a
classical cost function and you need to
run quickly and it's definitely at
finite temperature so and I should say
here that we at NASA have done some
experiments with some early expensive
experiments with quantum annealing and
have a better idea of what parameters to
set which work better or worse for
different problems but it's still very
early days because even because these
the d-wave machines are still pretty
small ours which is the biggest in the
world at least outside of d-wave has a
thousand 97 qubits which correspond to
about a thousand 97 binary variables so
you know we can see something but it's
not it's not going to solve practical
problems that you have in the room at
that small number of qubits so so
there's a there's a little chip inside
superconducting qubits and if you come
down to NASA we can show you not the
chip that's in the machine but but a
sister chip and then I seen a big cooler
thanks the question of what makes that
in the program yeah well we just thought
that this would be the perfect number to
experience no the reason is that it was
a 12 by 12 grid of 8 by 8 unit cells
you're suggesting that I point to the
picture here which gives a schematic not
how they actually look but a schematic
for the connections between the qubits
on here so each of the dots is a qubit
and you'll see they're eight in each of
the squares and the ones in the
horizontal sorry and keep getting
backwards the ones in the horizontal row
connect to the ones above and below the
ones vertical core connect horizontally
to the ones across and then the machine
at NASA has a 12 by 12 grid of these and
you're gonna tell me that's not 1097
that's 1152 well man you
Turing isn't perfect and some of the
qubits are sufficiently hard to
calibrate that it's just better not to
use them so but we have a thousand
ninety seven cubits that are that are
good and and so that's what that's what
we can play with what's a little review
on the chip what's the feature size oh I
don't remember Matt you know well the
cube itself is something like seven
hundred micron so yeah people are
starting to ask questions about sort of
the status of quantum hardware so we
have d-wave machines and in the near
future both d-wave and likely others
will produce larger and better quantum
annealer so where they're more qubits
there's more connectivity and there's
better control number of groups are
working on that and there's also likely
to be other special-purpose
quantum devices coming online
particularly for certain types of
quantum simulation okay now there's also
the question of what about a universal
quantum hardware and in superconducting
qubits a universal gate set and simple
error correction has been demonstrated
on nine cubits and near-term it's
expected within the next couple years
maybe two three years 50 to 100 cubits
with Universal gates at full control
which would be very very exciting that
would be well into the realm of what we
can't currently simulate classically and
so many of us are just really really
I'm gonna I'm incredibly excited when we
first started working on this I don't
know whether we'd live to see yeah we
didn't know if we'd live to see a
hardware where you could run something
beyond what's classically possible and
now with any luck we will we all managed
to see that and with any luck we'll be
able to play play with that there have
been impressive advances in other areas
ion traps optical etc it's not clear
what ultimately is going to win but
superconducting qubits are ahead at the
moment and breakthroughs are really
needed to obtain a fully scalable system
now people will often ask well why are
you you know when do you think that will
happen when when can you when will you
be able to factor a number of
cryptographic interest and I used to
have to just speculate on my own but
this month the NSA came out and said
prepare for quantum computers be ready
to have larger key sizes and whatever
else might be necessary but we're not
quite sure what's necessary because the
state of quantum resilient cryptography
is a little bit unclear but that's
another talk okay
you